[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 142 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc Campoy, and I'm
here with my ex-colleagues--
[LAUGHTER]
Melanie Warwick and Mark Mandel.
Hello, how are you doing?
MELANIE WARWICK: We're good.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: We're pretty good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very good.
MELANIE WARWICK: Welcome back.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
Thank you.
It's a pleasure to be back.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARWICK: Well,
we have you back today
because we are going to be
talking about Agones today.
And Francesc, you
were kind enough
to come back and help interview
Mark who, of course, is part
of this interview, since
this is his baby that he's
been working on for a while.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARWICK: And we finally
got around to talking about it.
We got around to talking
about it at Next.
And we had Francesc come back to
help us do the wrappers today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It was fun.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARWICK:
Seems about right.
MARK MANDEL: It was weird being
on this side of the table.
MELANIE WARWICK: Yeah.
It was weird.
[LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, for
once you're the victim.
That's good.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So as per always, we have
our Cool Things of the Week
and our Questions of the Week.
This week, since we
have Francesc here,
we're going to ask him, should
you do machine learning in Go?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I will answer.
[LAUGHS]
MELANIE WARWICK: You
will give the answer.
But we'll start off with
our Cool Things of the Week.
And for this week, you're able
to use Python 3 in App Engine.
And we have a blog post
that we will link to that.
Something we also
want to mention
is that next week
we will actually be
doing an episode on App Engine.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARWICK: So
you'll get to hear more
about that and some
of the announcements
that went on at Next as well.
MARK MANDEL: And continuing
on, talking about Python,
it's worth noting-- and we
talked about this at Next--
but Cloud Functions'
serverless platform
is now generally available.
So you can use it for
all your production
needs, which is pretty sweet.
We have an [INAUDIBLE]
all that good stuff.
You'll also get new language
runtime, so Node 8, Python 3--
or 3.7, actually,
to be specific.
MELANIE WARWICK: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: And there's all
sorts of other fun good stuff
in there.
I know, Francesc, you were
looking at something particular
you quite liked.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I saw something there
that is very cool,
because actually we
spoke about it a long
time ago, talking
about how connecting
to Cloud SQL
from Cloud Functions
used to be quite hard.
You needed to
install the Cloud SQL
Proxy, make sure it was running
correctly, and all that stuff.
And that has been
now fully managed.
So [INAUDIBLE] just
a click of a button.
And then you're good to go.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARWICK: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's a great thing.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, while we have
you, Francesc, I
think, did you just speak,
or did it just go live, or--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
talk just came out.
I gave it a couple
months ago in Chicago.
Yeah.
I gave a talk.
It's called "The Robustness
of Go," which is basically
about how robust is Go.
And the result is,
well, not much, really.
[LAUGHTER]
But who cares, because the
whole talk is about how,
well, Erlang is super robust.
And Erlang is not really robust.
It's the machine learning
behind Erlang that is robust,
which is a pretty interesting
thing, because people mix in
between languages and tooling.
And basically, the whole point
is about how Kubernetes is
bringing that robustness to all
of these other languages that
do not have it built in, because
they cannot really do that.
MARK MANDEL: Interesting.
MELANIE WARWICK: That's good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
just watch the video.
And like and subscribe.
No, sorry, that's YouTube.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARWICK:
Isn't everything
like and subscribe now?
So the link at the
bottom of wherever
I'm pointing, which of
course works really well
when you're on a podcast.
OK, so, another thing we
wanted to mention for this week
is that there is
a blog post we're
going to link to
that talks about how
to do a very easy
backup and replay
of streaming events using
Cloud Pub/Sub and Storage
and Dataflow.
And this is interesting to use,
especially-- a lot of people
out there right now
working with events,
different types of data.
So this is very valuable
to see how to do this,
and they take you
through step by step.
MARK MANDEL: Finally,
we've been talking
a bit about Java developers
lately, which is pretty cool.
So Spring Cloud GCP 1.0 is
now generally available.
This includes following
spring-boot-starter-integration,
including messaging
with Cloud Pub/Sub,
databases with
MySQL and Postgres,
file storage with Cloud Storage,
logging with Stackdriver
logging, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
So these Spring [? Grade ?]
integrations automatically
discover credentials
from the Cloud SDK.
Basically it does
all the good stuff
to make your life
a little bit easier
for getting up
and running on GCP
and having those integrations
with your Spring Cloud
applications.
MELANIE WARWICK: That's good.
Well, Mark, Francesc, I think
it's now time for us to go
talk with both of you again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, let's
go back in time to Cloud Next.
MELANIE WARWICK: Sounds good.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
MELANIE WARWICK: For
this week's episode,
we are excited that we're going
to be interviewing Mark Mandel.
[TRUMPET BLAST]
And more importantly,
Cyril Tovena.
CYRIL TOVENA: More importantly.
MELANIE WARWICK: Who is here
to talk to us about Agones,
finally.
Finally, we're
talking about Agones.
CYRIL TOVENA: Finally.
MELANIE WARWICK: It
took long enough.
But we have a special,
not exactly new--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
not exactly special.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARWICK: No,
you're always special.
Not new, but very special
that Francesc has come back
to help us interview Mark.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
Hello.
MELANIE WARWICK: Hello!
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Happy to be back.
MELANIE WARWICK: Well,
we're glad you're here.
And we're here, and we're
doing the interview at Next
as we speak.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARWICK: Well, so,
Cyril, we know who Mark is.
Tell us about yourself.
CYRIL TOVENA: So I'm
Cyril, like you said.
And I work for Ubisoft for the
last four years, approximately.
And I've been building web
services for games so far.
And currently I'm focusing
on helping game production
to develop a dedicated
game server in the cloud.
MELANIE WARWICK: Great.
CYRIL TOVENA: Yep.
MELANIE WARWICK: I
guess, Mark, maybe you
should tell those who are
listening at home who are you?
MARK MANDEL: Who am I?
MELANIE WARWICK: Why do we care?
MARK MANDEL: Why do we care?
OK, so I do a bunch of stuff.
My name is Mark Mandel.
I'm a developer advocate.
I do a lot of stuff for
Games at Cloud Cloud.
I guess founder,
co-founder-- something
like that-- of Agones.
Sure.
That works.
CYRIL TOVENA: Am I a co-founder?
MARK MANDEL: I
don't know, are you?
CYRIL TOVENA: I just
found out today.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: So yeah.
Agones came out of
some of the stuff
that I'd been doing
with Kubernetes and game
servers and the
collaboration that we
have here with Ubisoft as well.
So I've been doing
a lot of that work.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
remember you working
on this project
for quite a while,
but I didn't remember why.
[LAUGHTER]
So could you tell us a little
bit why Agones, what is it,
and why did you create it?
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So Cyril, you mentioned
something just before.
You were talking about
dedicated game servers.
Should we talk a little
bit about what those are
and why those are important?
CYRIL TOVENA: A game
server is [INAUDIBLE]
in multiplayer video games.
And the idea is it
actually receives
all the events of the player and
then you can do some game logic
and also send back the
information to all the players
so they can render the actual
[INAUDIBLE] on the console.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So dedicated game servers are
really important for, I think,
two particular reasons--
very fast-paced
multiplayer games,
so like your "Overwatches,"
and your "Fortnites,"
and those kind of games.
One of which is,
unfortunately, we
can't change the speed of light.
It would be really
nice if we could.
So being able to control the
physical location of where
all your players connect
to is really powerful.
So if we're playing a
game-- we're here at Next--
if we could put a server
that was actually in
[INAUDIBLE] that would be
great, because it's actually
close to us.
Ideally, we wouldn't want to
build a server in Australia.
That would be sad.
And the other fun
thing is, I don't
know if you've actually noticed
this, but people are horrible.
So-- [LAUGHS]
MELANIE WARWICK: Well,
that's a revelation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I did work
with you for quite a long time.
MARK MANDEL: I know,
so that's true.
And so you've definitely notice.
Melanie is still
working this out.
And so any time you give a
binary to someone or people
can see the traffic that
happens between systems,
they're going to introspect
it and try and cheat things.
Basically, if you have
a dedicated game server,
you can make it authoritative.
And it's one way of
helping with cheating.
Anything you want to--
CYRIL TOVENA: No, I think you
also talk about the latency.
I think this is something
that is very important.
When you have a game like a
FPS game, and a shooting game,
it's very important to
have a good latency.
So that's when you want to start
using dedicated game server.
MARK MANDEL: So, back to
your question, which was why.
MELANIE WARWICK: Yes, why.
MARK MANDEL: Why.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Actually,
before we get into the why,
does this mean that
you're rendering
the images and everything
on those servers?
Or it's just like the data about
like the events on the game?
CYRIL TOVENA: The data and
the events of the game.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, so
then basically that's
information that
then the client--
that is like whatever
doing up in GL
and crazy things to render it.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, cool.
OK.
CYRIL TOVENA: So some very
simple dedicated game servers,
they just forward back
the actual information
from one player to
the other players.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
CYRIL TOVENA: It could
be a very easy example.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: But
other game servers
will probably do,
like, full physics
simulation and everything--
CYRIL TOVENA: Yeah, exactly.
MARK MANDEL: --that's actually
happening inside the game
and what it's doing.
So yeah, why Agones?
So hosting and scaling
dedicated game servers
is a little different from
other types of applications.
So if you look at something like
a traditional web application--
it's stateless.
You could spin up
100,000 of them.
And if you kill
50,000 at one point,
as long as there's enough to
handle the load, nobody cares.
If you run a
database, the database
runs for probably
months or years on end.
So that's data you want
to persist to a disk.
Dedicated game servers,
I feel like this
is the thing that
sticks with me,
is like they sit
in this weird space
where before players
connect to them,
you could run 100,000 of
them, kill 50,000 of them,
and no one would care.
But as soon as players
connect to those
dedicated game
servers-- and they're
doing direct connections.
They're not going
through a load balancer.
As soon as you have a direct
connection and players playing
on them, you cannot kill those,
because players get really mad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Kind
of makes sense, yeah.
CYRIL TOVENA: And it's very
difficult to connect them back
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
CYRIL TOVENA: --to
another session.
MARK MANDEL: So Agones exists to
handle those sort of problems.
So being able to create
these game servers either
on demand or potentially
[? warm ?] versions of them
beforehand, and making
sure to control and manage
the lifecycle of
those game servers
so that once players are
connected to them, even if you
want to update
those game servers
or you want to scale
down or scale up,
you're not going to interrupt
those game sessions,
essentially.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you're using the term
"dedicated game server."
What is the other
alternative, when
it's not dedicated and server?
How do you do this?
CYRIL TOVENA: It's
actually peer connection.
So you connect players
altogether without a server.
So they directly
connect with each other.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, I see.
CYRIL TOVENA: That's
another option.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MELANIE WARWICK: And
who is using this?
Who's taking advantage of this?
MARK MANDEL: Of
dedicated game servers?
MELANIE WARWICK:
Yes, of using Agones?
MARK MANDEL: So Agones right
now is still fairly early.
It's alpha.
So literally, as of right now,
I am doing a 0.3.0 release.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yay!
MARK MANDEL: So we've got some
people who are playing with it
and some people who are
kind of working against it,
nothing that we can specifically
mention right now, I think,
is probably pretty accurate.
CYRIL TOVENA: Yep.
MELANIE WARWICK:
Working against it?
MARK MANDEL: Working
against it, you
know, trying it out
for a few things.
I think that works.
So we're getting
a lot of feedback,
which is really, really good.
We've still got some
features that we
want to have done on
the roadmap and will be
needed for a full 1.0 release.
But we're moving
forward pretty quick.
MELANIE WARWICK: And how
does the relationship
work with Ubisoft?
MARK MANDEL: They tell me
what to do and I do it.
[LAUGHTER]
CYRIL TOVENA: It's close, huh?
MARK MANDEL: Kind of.
CYRIL TOVENA:
Yeah, well, for me,
I think the relationship is
that Google Cloud is very
good at scaling containers.
They've been doing
that for a while,
especially with Kubernetes.
You're the cradle of
Kubernetes, so that's
why we are collaborating
together on this project.
And on all sides, I think since
we have a lot of online games,
we have the expertise of
running those online games.
And we can help
build that project,
and we know actually
what it takes
to run dedicated game servers.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I just want
to say it's been a real delight
and a pleasure working
with you on this project.
CYRIL TOVENA: Yes.
Same for me.
MELANIE WARWICK: Well, good.
Well, where did
the name come from?
[LAUGHTER]
CYRIL TOVENA: And how
do you pronounce it?
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So actually, I had this
conversation a little
while ago with a person I met.
Apparently I should
actually be saying "Ahones."
FRANCESC CAMPOY: "Ahones"?
MARK MANDEL: I could
be-- no, so I'm
going to say this
with a grain of salt.
I was told by someone
who speaks Greek.
So apparently Agones with
a hard G means elbows.
And "Ahones" comes from
a public competition.
It was like a precursor
to the Olympic games.
So normally at a public
gathering, you would have--
I love using the term
feats of strength.
But you'd have sporting
games and that kind of stuff.
So people would gather
for big public events,
and there would be competitions.
And I felt like
that would be kind
of appropriate for basically a
platform for multiplayer games.
Also, I got it
through legal review.
[LAUGHTER]
So, you know, there was that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's interesting.
So you're supposed to
pronounce it "Ahones"
or something like that?
How do you pronounce it?
MARK MANDEL: I have a
tendency to say Agones,
which I think is probably
more amusing, because it
means elbows.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sure.
MARK MANDEL: But I don't mind.
As long as you try the
platform and see if it works.
MELANIE WARWICK:
As well as maybe
contribute to the platform?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
contributing's great too.
MELANIE WARWICK: What are the
unique challenges for running
dedicated game servers?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You mentioned
before the fact that you cannot
just like downscale easily.
What other things there?
MARK MANDEL: OK, so
yeah, we talked a bit
before about how scaling down,
you can't just kill players.
They tend to get mad
when you do that.
So that's definitely
a unique challenge.
I think dedicated game
servers definitely also have--
well, outside of
the Agones space,
they have challenges
around CPU performance.
They're very CPU bound.
So you're doing a lot
of physics simulations
and sending a lot
of network traffic.
Network latency, we were
talking about that too,
is definitely a thing as well.
CYRIL TOVENA:
Versioning [INAUDIBLE]
is very complicated with
the client and the server.
It's very complicated to handle.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
there's communication,
things you need to consider.
So much like, say, for
example, if you were doing,
say, like a gRPC or
a REST-based service,
as you change as one
side goes to another,
you need to change both
the client and the server.
The same thing exists with
dedicated game servers.
CYRIL TOVENA: [INAUDIBLE]?
It needs to be available
pretty quickly, also.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Players tend to get mad if
they can't get on games really
quickly.
CYRIL TOVENA: They
don't like the wait.
MARK MANDEL: They really
don't like to wait.
They get really, really mad.
CYRIL TOVENA: Or they
play another game
if they have to wait.
MELANIE WARWICK: That
could be a problem.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How does
Kubernetes help with that?
What are the
components or features
of Kubernetes that make it
so Agones is a good match?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, this is
where I get really excited.
[LAUGHTER]
Kubernetes gives
a lot of the base
building blocks for
basically running processes
on big clusters of machines,
I think at a base level.
I think that's what it is.
And it has a declarative and API
driven approach to doing that.
And the other
thing that it gives
that I think is really exciting,
what makes Agones possible,
is it gives native
extensions internally.
So if you are familiar
with Kubernetes,
you have pods and
deployments and services,
like those kind of nouns.
And the phrase I like to use
is you can add your own nouns.
So Agones, for example, where
like here's a game server noun.
And we're going to tell
it how to extend it.
It's called a custom resource
definition and a controller.
But at the end of the day,
we're like, you install Agones.
And now suddenly
Kubernetes is like, oh,
I know how to
manage game servers.
That's cool.
Oh, I know how to manage
fleets of game servers,
because now I know
what a fleet is.
And I know how to manage
those in a declarative way
in exactly the same
way as you would
do with a YAML file
for a deployment.
You can do, say, a YAML file
for a fleet or a game server.
By the same token, you
can do the same thing
like through the Kubernetes API.
It extends both the YAML
definitions that you can apply,
as well as the Kubernetes API.
So Kubernetes knows
what game servers
are and can manage life
cycles and that kind of stuff.
CYRIL TOVENA: Yeah.
And one aspect that is very
interesting about Kubernetes
is it brings a lot of
things like log aggregations
that you don't have to do.
There is also the auto
scaling, and node selection.
There is a lot of very
interesting features
that you can take advantage
when you're using a game server.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
The other thing I
actually want to make
sure I bring up as
well, which I think
is really important, because
we talked about latency.
Kubernetes is really
important here,
because sometimes
players show up
in really weird
places in the world.
Sometimes you'll just
have a group of players
somewhere in the world,
and you're like, OK,
we need to get our
infrastructure somewhere
close to them so that we
can get close latency.
Now, maybe GKE or
another cloud provider
isn't necessarily going
to help you for that.
Maybe they are.
That gives you
some more options.
And maybe you just
need to get a co-lo
and stick Kubernetes in it.
And now suddenly you can run
your whole infrastructure.
So that kind of flexibility
is really important to us,
to allow you to run these
platforms in exactly the place
that you need them so that
your players can get the best
experience.
MELANIE WARWICK: Were there any
tradeoffs that you had to make?
MARK MANDEL: Some
really minor ones.
I'm thinking about some of
the stuff around [? Arback. ?]
[LAUGHTER]
There's some stuff that
we're still working out.
This gets really
nitty-gritty, but like
[? Arback ?] is applied at
a pod level, for example.
And we do some side car
stuff that enables access
to see what happens
inside the custom resource
definition and basically
the game server definition.
But we're looking at ways we can
lock that down a little better.
But otherwise, it's
been pretty OK.
Had to write some special health
checking stuff specifically
for games servers.
So by default, at
a pod level, you
can tell your pod to restart
if something fails or not.
But what we want instead
of-- if a game server fails
for whatever reason once
players are connected to it,
you don't really
want it to restart.
Because then if players
reconnect to a state
that was zero, then
weird stuff could happen.
So we want it to just die.
But before a player connects,
we want it to restart.
So we had to do some
custom logic for that,
which was kind of fun.
But yeah.
Odd stuff that Kubernetes
wasn't necessarily built for.
But mostly it's been
actually really, really good.
CYRIL TOVENA: Yeah.
I think it has been very
good, because Kubernetes has
been built to be extensible.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
CYRIL TOVENA: And
it has been very
easy to actually extend it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
the interesting thing
is I don't think that many
people use stateful containers
on Kubernetes.
Did you find any specific
issues where you got into that?
You were mentioning
that it's better
to die than just to restart.
Are there any other
things, like how
do you handle the fact
that if a connection goes
down temporarily,
do you just give up?
MARK MANDEL: So on
the Agones side,
we don't handle the
communication side of things.
We defer to the actual
game server implementation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, OK.
MARK MANDEL: We're pretty
hands-off in that way.
So we're like, you can make UDP
connections or TCB connections.
Most game servers use UDP.
And then it's kind of
application specific, I think,
is probably pretty accurate.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Mhm.
MELANIE WARWICK: Nice.
Cyril, what was it
like working with Mark?
CYRIL TOVENA: It was great.
[LAUGHTER]
CYRIL TOVENA: Nope.
MARK MANDEL: I was going to say.
I'll give you that money later.
CYRIL TOVENA: No, but for real.
[LAUGHTER]
CYRIL TOVENA: [INAUDIBLE]
MELANIE WARWICK: We can all
get together and compare notes
later.
What did you enjoy the
most about this project,
working on this project?
CYRIL TOVENA: Well, what
I enjoyed the most was--
while working with
Mark was nice,
and what I really liked
with the corroboration
was that Mark was able to
actually ask some Google
team when we were required.
And it was awesome, because
sometimes we are getting stuck
or we needed advice
on how to do stuff.
And he was able to do that.
So that was great.
MARK MANDEL: I
think, yeah, my would
be almost kind of the opposite.
It's been really great
to sit down with Ubisoft
and be able to be
like, OK, so if we're
doing this with game
servers and this happens,
what's the right way
for us to approach this?
Another thing is
a lot of it we've
done in the open,
which has been great.
It's all on GitHub.
We're all doing issues.
It's all on Slack.
Like everyone can come in
and come see what's going on,
pretty open about our
process and how we do stuff.
We're very open to anyone
coming in and contributing stuff
as well, which we've had,
which has been really great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do
you happen to know
of some metrics on the project,
like how many contributors,
and things like these?
Are you looking for
new contributors?
Are they easy issues that
people can contribute?
MARK MANDEL: I do
have those answers.
So we currently have
17 contributors.
There we go.
We are definitely looking
for more contributors.
We have Help Wanted
and Good First Issue
labels on our repository.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And what
primary language are you using?
[LAUGHTER]
CYRIL TOVENA: Go, obviously.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, interesting.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARWICK: Do you have any
specific questions around that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I mean, no.
Like I was going to
ask why you chose it,
but you're extending
Kubernetes, so I
guess it's the way to do it.
But actually, the question
would be the other way around.
Is there any
complaints about Go?
Like, anything that
you face that's like,
oh, I wish I was doing closure.
MARK MANDEL: It's the worst.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Just the worst.
MARK MANDEL: It's
just the worst.
It's just I hate it.
It's just the worse.
MELANIE WARWICK:
All the problems.
MARK MANDEL: No.
I mean, I personally like Go.
It's good for
getting stuff done.
Been using [INAUDIBLE]
as dependency management.
It's fine.
It works.
We haven't moved Vigo yet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh cool.
MARK MANDEL: I don't know
what's happening there.
MELANIE WARWICK: Well,
is there anything
you would do differently if you
were to do this all over again?
MARK MANDEL: I don't think so.
We go back and fix things if we
have decided it doesn't work.
Like an example of
that that's actually
coming in this release is
initially we were like, oh,
games servers--
or maybe I initially said it.
I don't know if it's a we.
It may have been a me thing.
Game servers only need one port.
And I was like, oh,
it will be fine.
And then everyone was like, no,
they need more than one port.
And I was like, OK,
let's change that.
So that's coming in
this version now.
It's actually some half decent
backward compatibility too,
so that's all working.
So we're pretty iterative,
especially being alpha as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What are
the plans for the future?
Like you just mentioned,
you're in alpha.
Is beta coming any time soon?
What about 1.0?
MARK MANDEL: Soon?
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For
some definition of soon.
CYRIL TOVENA: Soon, trademark.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that works.
No, we definitely
have big goals though.
There's a lot of
work to be done.
But the next big ticket
item's definitely
going to be around
visualization and statistic
management, that kind of stuff.
CYRIL TOVENA: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, which
we're pretty excited about.
So we want to do some
statistics around players,
like number of game
servers, visualizations
that kind of stuff.
But I think also do some
very standard metrics
for game servers, FPS
counts, lost frame
counts, and hitching,
and that kind of stuff.
Multicluster is top
of mind as well.
What else did I have on my list?
CYRIL TOVENA: Not auto scaling?
MARK MANDEL: Auto scaling.
Yes.
Yeah, that's another
thing that we
want to explore more as well.
CYRIL TOVENA: Maybe Windows,
if it gets more [INAUDIBLE]..
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so Microsoft's
been doing some pretty
amazing work with Windows
in Kubernetes, so we definitely
want to take advantage of that.
Windows is pretty huge in the
games industry for some reason.
CYRIL TOVENA: Yeah, it is.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For
the server side too, or?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh wow.
Interesting.
CYRIL TOVENA: Yeah, because
it's easier for the developers
when they're working on Windows.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Makes sense.
MELANIE WARWICK: You talked
a little bit before already
about how people can get
involved anything else you
wanted to say in regards to how,
if anybody wants to be involved
in building out Agones?
Anything else you want to share?
MARK MANDEL: Aboslutely.
Yeah.
So there is a
contributing guide.
It's definitely the
best place to start.
There's like a how to contribute
with a contributer's license
agreement, code of conduct,
that kind of stuff,
as well as a set of resources.
There's a developing,
testing, and building
Agones step-by-step
instruction guide
for basically getting
up and running.
We've got a whole
set of internal tools
that we use for making builds
and running tests and doing
all that kind of stuff.
So that is literally the
first place to start.
And we have it covering both
Windows and Linux and Mac,
and both running that on
Google Kubernetes Engine
as well as running
locally on Minikube.
So basically that is the
first place to start.
And if you have any issues,
that's the first thing.
Because then if
you can run that,
then you can compile things.
You can run tests, that
kind of stuff as well.
But it's been pretty cool.
We've had fly by contributions.
Recently we had someone
come by and was like--
so we have an integrated SDK
for lifecycle management.
And then we're like,
here's one for us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh yeah, nice.
MARK MANDEL: Here you go.
And we're like, cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's very nice.
MARK MANDEL: Which
is really neat.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So what if
I don't want to contribute,
but I want to use it.
Are you ready for that?
If anyone wants to
consider building a game
server using Agones,
is it a good moment,
or should they wait?
MARK MANDEL: I would say it
depends on what your plans are.
If you want to release
in the next six weeks,
maybe you don't.
If you want to release
sometime next year,
I think it's definitely
worth having a look at,
especially if you don't
want vendor lock in
and you want to be able to
run your stuff anywhere.
I think that's pretty accurate.
And I think it's also
a good opportunity
as well to be able
to be like, OK,
we can help shape
what this looks like
as this goes through,
which I think
is kind of exciting, especially
if you're looking at all
the other options
and you're like,
OK, I guess we're going to
have to build this myself,
for whatever reason.
Might as well do it with
a bunch of other people
as well who's doing
it in the open.
We can all help each other
come to really good go goal.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
CYRIL TOVENA: We're getting
a lot of support on Slack
also, to some extent,
as much as we can.
So I guess people can
come to the [INAUDIBLE]
and ask questions.
There's already a lot of people
asking if they can use it now.
And there's people
experimenting it.
So they can share with
themselves and with us also.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
The biggest problem,
I think, is actually
keeping up with demand,
which has been--
it's a good problem to have.
No, there are builds as well.
You don't have to
build it yourself.
We're currently releasing
every six weeks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: So we
do an RCF to five
and then we do a full
release after six,
on the six week,
which is why I need
to do the full release today.
MELANIE WARWICK: As we speak.
MARK MANDEL: But yeah,
it's coming together.
We're putting together a
little governance model,
and it's all pretty sweet.
MELANIE WARWICK:
Cyril, anything else
you wanted to add that we
haven't already covered?
CYRIL TOVENA: I accept
that it has been great,
but I already said that.
And you can go to agones.dev.
You know, that's it.
MELANIE WARWICK: Great.
CYRIL TOVENA: Thank you.
MELANIE WARWICK:
Mark, anything else?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
If you're interested in any
way, shape, or form, please,
there's a Google Group.
There's Slack.
Follow us on Twitter @agonesdev.
Reach out in any
way, shape, or form.
We'll definitely be interested
in chatting with you
and talking some
more about Agones
and seeing if you want to come
and help out in any way, shape,
or form.
MELANIE WARWICK: Well, Francesc,
thanks so much for coming back
to help me do this interview.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It was a pleasure.
MELANIE WARWICK:
And Mark and Cyril,
thank you so much for being here
for the interview for today.
CYRIL TOVENA: Thank
you for having me.
MARK MANDEL: It was
weird being on this side,
but thank you for having me.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARWICK: Thank you.
CYRIL TOVENA: You'll
get used to it.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARWICK:
Thanks again, Mark,
for coming on the podcast
to talk to us about Agones.
It was really nice of you.
MARK MANDEL: It was
my pleasure, actually.
And thanks to Cyril
for joining me as well.
It was--
MELANIE WARWICK:
More importantly.
MARK MANDEL: Probably
more importantly.
MELANIE WARWICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I
don't have a choice.
I'm here every week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
was a great interview,
great hosts this time.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARWICK: I know.
That was it specifically.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
specifically great hosts.
MELANIE WARWICK: All
right for this week,
as Mark mentioned at the
beginning, the Question
of the Week is, of
course, should you
do machine learning with Go?
Francesc, since you're our Go
expert, what are your thoughts?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
[LAUGHS] There's two answers.
One is the quick answer,
which probably, no.
MELANIE WARWICK: Probably?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Probably not.
MELANIE WARWICK: You
seemed much more emphatic
about that earlier.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Let's
just say that if you're
starting from
scratch, and you're
learning about machine learning,
probably just stick to Python.
That is the ecosystem
where you're going
to find all the libraries.
You're going to
find all the help.
So it totally makes
sense to start
with Python or any other
language that you know already
and just keep on learning.
I think actual tools.
Don't learn Go just to
do machine learning.
Because it's probably
not the best thing to do.
That said, though,
since I joined Source,
we've been doing a lot
of machine learning.
And I've been trying to teach
people that know already Go how
to do machine learning in Go.
Because I think
that's a very nice way
to learn really how
it works for real,
like what are the
maths behind it.
So I give a talk about
that doing dotGo in Paris
back in November 2017,
which was like my first day
as a non-Googler.
And also I gave a talk in
Paris at the same time.
It was a fun day.
And since then, I've
also been doing like just
for fun episodes
and stuff like this.
And basically, the experience
is you can definitely do it.
You can try.
You can write all of
the algorithms in Go,
and it kind of works,
but not as fast.
Mostly because when
you're running it in Go,
you're going to end
up not using correctly
the CPU, because there's
like X specific instructions
from some CPUs done
specifically for this.
And by default, you
will not be using those.
Also, you will not be using
GPU, because Go's and GPUs don't
go well together.
So there's a couple
libraries that people
that might be wanting to try
this might be interested in.
One is gonum, which
is NumPy but for Go.
It's gonum.
And the cool thing
about this is that it
solves one of the
problems, which
is the fact that when you are
calling libraries, if you're
on a platform that supports
a specific instruction,
that instruction will be used.
So in general, any algorithm
that you write using gonum
is going to be faster.
So yeah, like you do [INAUDIBLE]
they're going to say,
rather than doing--
oh, I'm going to do a for
loop to these two vectors,
you just do like floats.add
or something to that.
MELANIE WARWICK: Sometimes
people say tensors.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Tensors, yeah.
So that's the whole idea.
You go towards tensors without
really saying the word tensors,
because you talk about floats.
Because it's just
slices and arrays.
Then there's gorgonia,
which is the one
that people should
be using if they want
to be training things in Go.
It works really well.
It's not full feature yet,
but it works quite well.
And it uses the GPU,
which means that now you
can start doing things
that are quite fast.
The last thing, though,
is that most people do not
want to train things in Go.
What they want to
do is they want
to have little binary that
uses a trained model that
has been trained with TensorFlow
or something like that.
And for that, you can
use TensorFlow for Go.
Because you can use
perfectly trained models,
load them, and run them, but
you can not train new ones, yet.
MELANIE WARWICK: Not yet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hopefully--
MELANIE WARWICK: One day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --it
will come one day,
but for now, I've seen
a couple pull requests.
I think the support
for variables,
right now there's
only placeholders.
So then you can not do much
with variables in TensorFlow,
unfortunately.
So yeah, that will
come sometime soon.
I don't work at Google, so
I don't know information
like this.
But hopefully soon, yeah.
MELANIE WARWICK: Well,
thank you for that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: My pleasure.
MELANIE WARWICK: I think one
other question I have for you,
how has it been?
Do you miss the podcast?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I do not miss
the podcast, because I actually
listen to it quite often.
It's on my phone.
Any time someone says things
like, oh, yeah, you know--
because when I, personally,
created the podcast--
and that's Mark.
He's kind of implying
that I was not involved.
MARK MANDEL: You're
still bitter about that--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I listen
to these things, you know.
MELANIE WARWICK: We saw your
tweet with the video reaction.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's happened again.
Last weekend I was
driving around.
And I don't know what it was,
but he said something where it
was like, Mark, I'm listening.
[LAUGHTER]
So just a warning,
I am listening.
MELANIE WARWICK: Always.
MARK MANDEL: We
created it together.
It's fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
No, it's been great.
I left Google.
But I didn't leave it that
much, because I'm still
a Google Developer expert for Go
and Cloud and machine learning.
So I was at Cloud Next.
And whenever there's
an event, I'm
always around-- working
less than before,
which is even better.
So yeah.
MELANIE WARWICK: That's great.
And I'm sure also not
having to be on top of this
every single week is also
a little bit relaxing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Are you implying
I don't like talking to Mark?
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARWICK: Potentially.
Potentially, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Well, next topic.
MELANIE WARWICK:
Anyway, all right.
For the last thing
we always like
to cover is, where
are we going to be?
So Francesc, where
are you going to be?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
very, very soon I'm
actually going to Gopher
Con at the end of the month.
I think it's August 26 or 27.
I'm going to be
teaching a workshop
and talking also about
machine learning in Go.
It's going to be
a very short talk,
but basically I'm going to
try to blow everyone's minds
with a demo written in Go,
analyzing Go using machine
learning that also does Go.
It's Go everywhere, basically.
It's going to be fun.
MARK MANDEL: Go
all the way down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
And then after that,
I'm going for a very
well-deserved-- at least
in my opinion-- holiday.
And after that, I'll be at GoSF
speaking in September-- again
about a similar topic,
machine learning, Go,
and stuff like that.
Yep.
MELANIE WARWICK: Great.
MARK MANDEL: Where
are you off to?
MELANIE WARWICK: I will be
off to South Africa, where
I will be at Deep
Learning [INAUDIBLE],,
so if you're there,
please come by and say hi.
And I will also be at
another conference,
finally, with Mark
after that, which
is going to be Strange Loop.
MARK MANDEL: Yes!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Jealous!
MARK MANDEL: You should come.
MELANIE WARWICK:
Why don't you come?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, 'cause
I cannot because I am traveling
and stuff.
Actually, anyone going
to Velocity in New York?
MARK MANDEL: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No?
I'll be there.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sad.
I thought you would
be there maybe.
MELANIE WARWICK: We
don't want to hang out
with you after this.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's fine.
MARK MANDEL: It's fine, yeah.
So I will be speaking
at PAX Dev in Seattle
at the end of the month
and then hanging out
with all my gamer friends at
PAX West right after that.
I will also be at Tokyo Next.
I'll be speaking at the game
day, so it'll be fun too.
And yeah, we're going to both
hang out at Strange Loop.
MELANIE WARWICK: Yes.
We will both be there.
So yeah, I think that's
it for us this week.
Francesc, Mark, thank you both
for joining me on the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
MELANIE WARWICK: And Mark,
you and I will be here again
next week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]